could i have picked a more boring video
topic
debatable today we're going to talk
about how to set up a documentation
website i am on the edge of my seat now
jokes aside this is actually going to be
a good experience because you guys are
with me and i'm not going to put you
through a bad experience the thing is
writing documentation and putting it up
onto a web server does not have to be
tedious documentation is everywhere
there should be some documentation about
how to get my bloody hair and
documentation is everywhere i think that
having a good solution for documentation
being able to write good documentation
for whatever it is that you're working
on and in fact even if you just need to
get some some information onto a website
we can take it and turn it into an
elegant process and that's exactly what
we're going to do today now i'm making a
game engine called hazel as most of you
know we're only now beginning to kind of
get people to actually use this engine
to make games and so it's becoming more
and more important to actually make
documentation to write documentation for
the engine so i set up this website
docs.hazelengine.com now it's not
anything fancy because it really just
needs to do its job well and that is to
provide people with documentation with
information however i took it upon
myself to try and make this as
nice of a process as possible to make it
as easy as possible for anyone working
on hazel to add to the documentation or
change it and also make it flexible
enough where we could kind of include
anything we wanted so today right here
i'm actually going to take you through
how to create something like
docs.hazelen.com
from scratch like literally from
purchasing a server signing up for a
hosting plan all the way through to
actually having this website and even
though documentation is like the
specific example we're going to be
looking at today this like whole process
can actually be used to set up any
website if you just want a website that
you can easily update and it's kind of
pain-free and you don't even have to log
into a web server or anything you can
definitely do that here so what on earth
am i talking about and how does this
even work well it's very simple
basically this entire website is just
made out of markdown files what we do is
we write whatever content we want in
markdown and then all we have to do is
commit and push our changes whether that
be adding pages modifying pages doing
anything really and then once we've
pushed that to git our website is just
magically updated
that's it
that's all there is and look you can
even like search for stuff by just
hitting the s key
magic so let's take a quick overview of
how all of this works so first of all
why markdown markdown is a markup
language i guess it's honestly becoming
like one of my favorite word processes
if you could even call it that just
because it's so easy when you're writing
something to just i guess mark up your
words or should i say mark down your
words and be able to easily control how
they appear i remember using this back
in university to output pdf files as
well instead of using something like
microsoft word you know as an engineer
it's just faster for me to open up vs
code and just write something i'm sure i
don't need to sell most of you guys on
the idea of markdown it's great and of
course a huge benefit is that it is just
text so
you know you don't need to worry about
what is this proprietary file format or
anything like that everything is right
there in the markdown we just need
something to be able to render it now
there is a lot of stuff out there that
can take your markdown files and convert
it into like pdf or html files if you
want to just write an entire book in
markdown you can just convert it to a
pdf file print it and it's going to look
beautiful but for a website we really
just want html files we want to write
our stuff in the markdown format and
then just have something to convert it
to html it should be pretty simple
because markdown is quite simple itself
and you can actually write a lot of html
code within markdown if you want to
there's actually plenty of stuff that
does that for you as well and i've
actually trialled a bunch of it but my
favorite by far is something called md
book this little app which is written in
rust by the way yeah that got your
attention simply takes a bunch of your
markdown files and makes like a book out
of it and that book could be like a site
but it could also be like a pdf document
so the plan is quite simple all you have
to do is basically list out the markdown
files that you want included as part of
your site you can organize them like
however you want really and then you
just tell it to build and then what it
does is it takes all that stuff and
outputs html files along with like a
whole bunch of boilerplate javascript
and css and all that stuff to actually
make the website work it does that super
quickly and it produces a website that
looks great on like all devices okay
cool so we have something that can
generate html files from our markdown we
just need a server to be able to host
those html files and like you know serve
them that's what servers do but then we
still have the problem of having to
update those markdown files somehow on
the server that can get annoying and
that's that sounds a bit tedious and
once those markdown files have been
updated we need to rebuild the website
so how do we make that easier that's
where the whole gear repository thing
comes in what we can do is actually set
up a git repository using github using
gitlab whatever really store our entire
collection of markdown files there along
with any empty book like metadata create
a web hook that notifies our server
whenever a new commit is pushed to that
repository so then the server can pull
the latest changes and just build the
book again beautiful that means that you
can add as many collaborators as you'd
like into that git repository and
whenever they push the site gets updated
so how do we set this up
well step one we need a server and for
that we're going to be using hostinger
the sponsor of today's video for those
of you who watch my other videos you
know that i love hosting and i have a
great partnership with them they're
honestly my favorite web host out of all
the ones that i've tried and they're
extremely affordable and super high
quality i'll leave a link in the
description below where you can sign up
for this particular video i'm going to
be using one of their vps servers we
need a vps server so that we have full
root access so that we actually have
full control over our server we can set
it up however we like if you are signing
up for a new plan using my link in the
description below don't forget to use
the coupon code ceno to get an extra
discount and if you're using any other
web host you're dead to me that's
totally fine most of this video will be
the same now once you've got yourself a
shiny new server using hostinger you'll
see it over here ready for setup the
setup itself is pretty simple you just
give your server a name a location a
root password and you choose an
operating system i'm just going to go
with the latest version of ubuntu it'll
take a few minutes for the vps to be
built and you can see we have all of the
details here now if i just browse to the
ip address of the vps you can see that
apache 2 has already been installed and
we see this page i'm not going to bother
setting up a domain or anything like
that for this example just gonna use the
ip address so let's go ahead and ssh in
now i like using windows terminal which
is this new thing that they've released
you can get it on the windows store it's
pretty nice let's ssh into our server
and you can see that obviously with the
vps we have full control over just the
root of everything now as a quick little
side note for hazel's documentation
server i actually used engine x instead
of apache hosting it has plenty of nice
documentation on how to set it up as
does digitalocean this is basically the
guide that i followed to set that up
however for this example since apache 2
is already installed and actually works
really nicely with php out of the box
we're just going to stick with apache
speaking of which let's go ahead and
open up our site configuration file
using vim of course and we'll just set
our document root that is where the
website exists on our drive to be inside
com.documentation website public this is
just like a convention i use for my
websites now to make that take effect we
have to restart apache if this was a
real setup i would probably make my own
configuration file rather than editing
the default one as i did but this is
totally fine let's make this document
root directory that i just added to that
apache configuration file and we'll just
add an index.html file but simply says
hello now let's refresh our web page and
look at that we're web developing now
since we'll be using php for our web
hooks we need to make sure the php is
installed and working correctly let's
write some php code and make sure that
our server can execute it and there we
go lol let's install php once that's
done and we've restarted apache much
better result now as a quick little
sanity check to make sure everything is
working correctly with php we can just
run this php info function and if we go
back to our web page you can see that it
displays all the information we want
such as the configuration file location
and the settings we've got enabled and
now we can finally begin with our
documentation website so we're going to
be obtaining md book i'll leave a link
to this in the description below if you
actually go to the releases they have
pre-built binaries for like all
platforms so we're going to take this
linux one obviously copy that link
address and then to make things easier
we're gonna go to our bin directory at
the root of our server and just download
that file there and then unzip it on
turret now because we place it into that
bin directory which is part of our path
we should be able to switch back to our
website directory and simply run mdbook
and as you can see everything works if
this is your first time using mdbook i
highly recommend you check out their
documentation which it itself is
actually using mdbook of course they've
got a fantastic easy to read simple
guide on how to actually get up and
running with this so we're going to call
mdbook init at the current directory
it'll ask us some questions and generate
a whole bunch of files mdbook build is
the only thing we have to run to
actually build the site from the raw
markdown files and once we've done that
if we navigate to the book directory
using our browser you can see our built
site up and running now i don't really
want to have to go slash book in the
browser of course the root of the
website should be that book directory so
if we go back to our site configuration
file we can just update the document
root and restart apache now as you can
see we can get rid of that slash book
and we wind up in the same place now i'm
not gonna give a complete tour of md
book here this book dot toml file has
the main kind of configuration for this
book remember what we're building here
really is a book not a site it can be
accessed as a site but you can also like
export it to a pdf it's great we're
making a book now this summary file
inside the source directory is very
important this lists not only like the
sidebar navigation links to every single
page but this is the index of every page
you want included in your book it will
not be built if it's not in here so make
sure that every markdown file you want
to be part of your book is listed here
let's go ahead and add this home page
page as an example we're listed in the
summary file along with its path and
then we can just simply make the file
and this is just your regular markdown
let's add some example text we'll run md
book build to actually build the site
and then just simply refresh it it's
that easy now it's uh hurting my eyes a
little bit here but luckily mdbook comes
right out of the box with a bunch of
themes you can of course make your own
we won't get into that in this video but
the included themes are great as well
and that's basically it that should be
enough to get you started it is just
markdown so let's go to hazelanger.com
as an example copy that image add it as
a link you get the point super easy if
you need to make subdirectories because
of course your website will presumably
grow especially if it's documentation
just make more directories make more
pages more markdown files and then just
add them to that summary it's also super
easy to make links between pages so here
you can see i'm linking back to the home
page from the home page i'm linking to
that additional page i just made all
you're doing here is creating like a
markdown link to the markdown file not
to the future html file or anything like
that specifically to the markdown file
after adding our new page to the summary
file and building you can see the fruits
of our labor and that's it for the basic
setup like you you're ready to go you're
you've got a website now let's take a
look at how we can actually set up some
web hooks using github to automate this
as a side note docs.hazelengine.com is
actually using git lab so the process
was a little different for like when i
set it up but in this video i thought
i'd use github since that seems to be
more popular the process is like 90 the
same we'll make a new repository on
github i'll just call it documentation
website to be honest i'm not sure if
this level of detail is really that
necessary for this video but there's
something satisfying about showing the
entire process you know let me know what
you think in the comment section below
let's install git on our server and
clone the repository i'm just going to
steal that git directory move it into
the current directory so our current
kind of book directory becomes the git
repository directory and then we can
just commit and push everything now uh
github specifically has these
authentication tokens that you need to
set up you can't simply use your
username and password like you can with
gitlab so we've got to set that up as
well finally we've pushed our data now
let's set up that web hook super easy to
set up we just going to the settings for
our repository webhooks add webhook and
then we need to provide a payload url
this is the url that github will
basically send a bunch of data to
whenever there is some kind of event so
for us that's just going to be a push
event it's going to send some data into
that url and we'll just write some code
to receive that data and do something
now there is one little caveat with our
setup the root of our website actually
points specifically to that built book
directory that is regenerated every time
we build using empty book so what i'm
doing here is creating an alias so that
if the url contains slash hook it
actually points to a different directory
where we can have a php file that will
receive that data from github and
actually do something now let's create
that directory make an index.html file
to test it out and make sure that that
alias is set up correctly as you can see
it works now let's rename the file to
update docs.php that's going to be where
our payload gets sent from github i'll
paste that url into github and we'll
change the content type to be json in
case you are doing something a bit more
sophisticated json will just be easy for
php to pass and retrieve any metadata
that you might need but this will set
you up for something deeper now you can
see that github actually sent like an
initial ping with a bunch of data here
in the payload i thought this would be a
good reference to refer to us to what we
can expect in terms of data but i was
wrong as you'll see later read the
documentation like this video is
literally about creating documentation
but like you also have to read
documentation that's important
oh my gosh why didn't it fall so much
today anyway let's move on and write
some php code that will actually receive
that data we'll just grab all of it and
put it into json decode which will let
us access the data in an object-oriented
way i'll also write this little log
message utility function so that we can
log what's going on to a file since
github will be the one executing this
script and i want to see what's going on
now if we run that script ourselves by
just refreshing our web browser going to
that url you can see we don't have a log
file so what's going on let's make sure
we're actually logging something but no
still no log file so maybe there's like
an error or something let's go back and
call phpinfo so that we can find out
where our php configuration file is
located and then we can edit it and set
display errors to on so that that script
will actually give us a response as to
what's happened and now if we run it
again you can see we have a warning fail
to open stream permission denied that's
because we made that directory as root
of course but our web server is not
running as root and it definitely should
not so what we need to do is change the
owner of this directory to www data
because as you can see that's what's
actually running our web server and then
we'll have permission to make files now
permissions are a hot topic in the realm
of web development and i'm not going to
pretend to be an expert in that so let's
just move on log is working however we
have this weird like new line not
actually being escaped and uses a new
line i don't know why i put single
quotes didn't work so let's change it to
double quotes and magically it works
great php now since we're meant to be
logging that payload let's redeliver the
message from github since it actually
contains json data but you can see
nothing got printed let's go back to our
php file actually before we do that
github has this useful response tab
which contains the body so i like the
response of that php file and because
we're displaying errors and all that we
can actually see a stack trace it's not
printing anything because we're
accidentally trying to log that json
object instead of a string so let's just
change it to input and redeliver that
github payload excellent that's all of
our data now let's do something useful
with it referring to the example payload
back in our php file let's access that
events array and check to see whether it
contains a push event if it does we'll
just log something and again if we
redeliver that payload you can see that
it works now a quick little note we
don't actually have to do any of this
for our scenario because every event is
a push event but again i'm just showing
you a deeper example now let's finally
write some real code so what do we
actually want to happen when we receive
a push event well let's log something
just for diagnostics and then i want to
execute a bunch of commands first of all
let's change directory into the root
directory of our repository of our book
and then let's do a git pull to receive
that latest push and then we'll just
call mdbookbuild to build our book now
i'm using the shell exec function and
storing the result in that result
variable so that i can actually see the
output to make sure that we get that
error stream also going into that result
variable we have to do this two right
angular bracket ampersand one i did a
dollar sign one in the git pull so
that's why it's not gonna work here but
after i fix it you can see that we get
that error output from git going right
into our log file so we can see what's
going on now again we get a permissions
error because of course the dot git
directory was also created by a root and
we're trying to execute it through www
data and by execute of course the php
script is a thing being executed but
it's trying to write to that dot git
directory because that's just part of a
git pull so let's just go ahead and make
that entire public directory be owned by
www data that's kind of my purpose for
creating a public directory that's owned
by like the web server and now you can
see we successfully get pull and build
our book brilliant so that's basically
up and running now all that remains is
testing it so i'm going to clone this
repository on my actual computer and
then open it up in vs code this is
usually what i use to write markdown
they have this brilliant preview window
as you can see that will preview your
entire markdown including like images
and stuff like that links will even work
let's add some random text just to test
it out and push i'm just going to set up
these windows side by side here so we
can see both the log output of our
server as we actually push that commit
so we've pushed
and
nothing
c
i'm going to spare you guys the details
here and show you this very sped up
footage of me
diagnosing and fixing this problem so
the problem was github somewhat lied
well
deceived me as far as what would be
included in the json payload if you
actually look at their documentation you
can see there is no events array there
is no hook section if you have just a
push event it sends you this so with
that in mind let's go back to our php
script and get rid of some of this code
that tries to look for that events array
and the push event i mean if we're only
sending push events then as long as the
json input isn't null we can assume it
probably came from github no one else
should really be sending us any payload
but either way if the json was passed
successfully let's just go ahead and
execute our script to pull and build
third time lucky and here's the push
beautiful there's that git pull being
executed successfully and our book being
built and if we refresh our page of
course it has been updated so yeah
that's pretty much it it's working
perfectly let's try one more time let's
make an entirely new page here i'll
actually just write a little c plus
hello world example don't forget to go
into the summary file and add your new
page and that's it if we just do another
git commit and push our server should
receive everything and you can see that
our website has been updated with that
new page amazing and that's it that was
probably the most fun part of your
entire documentation experience because
now you actually have to write the
documentation i hope you guys enjoyed
this video i hope that it was helpful if
you did enjoy it please don't forget to
hit the like button below why is this
pillow falling this channel is mostly
about c plus plus and game engines so
it's a little weird to have some web dev
stuff here but the truth is like web is
everywhere like it's inevitable to make
it through a development career without
really interfacing with the web servers
so i thought i'd kind of take you guys
through what i had to do for for hazel
let me know what you thought in the
comment section below don't forget to
check out hosting using my link in the
description below with that coupon code
channel and i will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you